let's start with medium as the page gets
larger we can see that the text reflows
that's good but that's not a breakpoint
but once the viewport is wide enough we
see that the images got larger and so
did the text that's a breakpoint once
the viewport is this wide we can see
that there's now a margin on this side
of the page that is another breakpoint
so in the medium.com example i noticed
two break points in the min width max
width example we start off and the page
says no then it gets a little bit larger
and the page says yes but if we get too
big it goes back to no so this means
that the course example also has two
breakpoints